my name is Charlie father and I'm 16 and
I was wondering if the James Webb Space
Telescope is going to give us results
rapidly or he's going to take a few
years to give us results okay Charlie
you're wondering whether the telescope
will give us results right away or will
take many years so some of both we
anticipate that will point the telescope
it's a very beautiful and important
objects right away as soon as we can and
within a few months after the telescope
is ready to observe will be having some
beautiful science to tell you about but
some projects just take a long time when
we want to study the most distant
universe we have to stare in one
direction for months at a time to get
the information we need because the
things we're trying to see or so faint
other times we just have to wait for an
event to occur if we know that a star is
going to have a planet that goes in
front of it and block some starlight we
have to wait for the day that that
occurs so all of these things have can
be scheduled in planned ahead but we
planned that the observatory will last
at least five years and hope for ten